yeah men even treat they're just like
kids we wash it we take care of it we
name it we go you want to see a photo
people go no thank you
the only difference is you beat your kid
at the mall nobody stops you
taste buds they come into the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two Fool's
gonna fight but only one food can be
right taste buds man yeah they're coming
to them all right welcome to
t-a-s-t-e budge today we got a special
guest here
hey good to be here he's been here
before he's back again Mark Norman
everybody oh yeah thank you great new
studio pimp looks gay this is good good
to see you babe
uh you got a very Risky Business thing
happening right now oh thank you yeah
you should don't tempt me I'll get in my
tidy whities and slide across this you
ever try it oh yeah of course all summer
I do that as a kid I must have oh my god
with the right floor and the right socks
you'll do it all night long you'll get
addicted I like that old time Rocky I
hate the song though right tell you I
just can't take it it's just like uh
that's an American black or like uh I
love rock and roll shoot me in the face
yeah I've heard it too much it's no good
all right
my biggest one is a Brown Eyed Girl oh
Blister in the Sun I I I'll
um
oh how about this one sweet dreams are
made of these that's good I can't handle
that song oh that's good
the opening beat is sick hate it can't
handle it built this city can't stand it
Sweet Caroline take a walk
oh wait oh wait you know what one I
really hate Don't Stop Believing oh
oh yeah
yeah let's be honest when you're in a
car alone you're gonna belt it
this is melting that and you're not
shit-faced there's something no no no
this is the only drive when I'm shifting
[Laughter]
post
pranos I can't do it anymore that's the
one right that's the one yeah yeah it's
it's it makes me want to like I'd throw
up in my mouth a little bit uh I gotta
I'm gonna happen to uh Gandolfini that's
what killed him all right I'm gonna out
Mark and myself on something here now I
saw Mark yesterday Fourth of July
fireworks and we are both wearing the
same shirt we were wearing yesterday
I'll do you one better I showered and
put it back on
hey all right I'll tell you right now
yesterday and today have been the
hottest days in New York so high I mean
it I mean it's stifling it's it's
painful so what in the world why
wouldn't you just go go to the next tea
the next clean teeth I got home because
I live in New York that's not why no I'm
telling you I'm telling you there's
there's a there's a chain of events I
guarantee you when you come to Earth is
not why I do the fluff and fold because
my building doesn't have laundry okay if
I do the fluff and fold I get my
t-shirts back no matter how nice they
fold them when you unfold them they're
notoriously wrinkled and I gotta steam
them so sometimes I'll get home after a
long steam t-shirts yeah you put them
out there Hannah Ross yeah
if you walk along long enough it'll
derive just smooth it out yeah it
depends on how wrinkled it is but as a
what are you doing in these t-shirts
it's a lifelong bachelor I like to walk
out with a would have finally a press
t-shirt as long as it's dirty Bachelor
you're wearing jean shorts yeah
you think the cutoffs have ever held the
kid back I mean you're nuts these are an
attribute thinking of nuts
yeah no I uh no I I just I I how did it
come to pass that you want the same
t-shirt twice I'm trying to get to it
like a 12 year old girl in Malibu what
are you wearing this is when do you have
a summer outfit all right yeah it's a
summer outfit
I mean I can't believe you're in pants
today though so am I I guess I just
can't do shorts yeah really what well
also I'm gonna go I'm going right to
spots from here so I couldn't do the
shorts all right dude you're doing
you're going to the spots in that
t-shirt now see that's now you've gone
oh man I'm out they can't smell me from
the audience uh sometimes so anyway yeah
I take the T-shirt out of the out of the
fluff and fold bag it's they're often
even though nicely folded very wrinkled
when they unfold I gotta steam it
because I hate a wrinkled shirt uh
and some days I'll get home and I'll
take my t-shirt off and I'll go this
still is clean it doesn't smell no pit
smell and it's very nicely unwrinkled so
I lay it I lay it carefully on my
dresser so it hangs there it doesn't
wrinkle again and I go now that's one
less thing I gotta worry about tomorrow
bring that back three days later you
can't go back to that first of all you
guys get wrinkled again yesterday was
the grossest day on I mean yesterday was
disgusting the air quality I didn't
leave my house till 6 p.m yesterday I
didn't sweat at all
nobody believes that I don't care if you
really saw him yesterday was he sweaty
uh not really do you know you played a
little beer pong that was about the
extent of the activities yeah we sat in
the it was pretty shady for the
first part we drank heavily all right
well I don't know
smell the shirt doesn't smell all right
let's go it smells good
thank you that does smell good no don't
smell mine
wait why did you do it uh well I don't
want to go do laundry so I try to milk
as much out of that shirt as I can get I
mean I do the undies I do the same I
don't do that wow that's that's I've
done with the T-shirt but not when I'm
outside smoking like a married man oh
all married I flip it because there's a
whole nother World on the other side
oh wait you turn them inside out you
mean and re-wear them wow that's quit
dude
oh no way you don't re-wear socks well
you know when you can't re-wear a sock
if I put on a socket and I go to the
market and come back I'll wear that sock
the next day okay if I'm hoofing it all
over town on traipsing around doing
spots yeah those can't go back on you
know that's gonna damage the shoe now
your shoe's gonna your shoe is gonna get
that smell and now every sock you put
into that shoe is gonna have that smell
[Laughter]
it's pretty bad I mean a scale of one to
ten that's a that's a 19.
go ahead in there get up don't worry
because I want a genuine a pin
oh
wow that was involuntary that's
involuntary man did you see that he
didn't even mean to this I saw it happen
in volunteer that smells like moldy it
doesn't smell like bad feed it smells
moldy it's probably got some Katrina in
there I had sex today
dude I'm seeing spots I'm not kidding
yeah it's no joke wait but so so never
mind the socks because ever you put a
fresh pair of socks in there they're
done oh the socks will get stinky
immediately nice it doesn't matter and
now you know if you ever go to someone's
house I don't have shoes on I don't
allow shoes in my house okay I mean I
ask people to take them off you're gonna
have a problem if you ever go to
something I always do yeah how old are
those shoes I don't know uh seven months
that's crazy Mark really no seven month
old shoe should smell like that wow yeah
I'm serious these are my newest pair
dude these are these are three years old
those are great for three years I I'm
big on the shoe upkeep yeah they make
fun but I take care of this stuff Jean
short thank you dress like Marianne you
gotta get yourself some Pine inserts
wow that smells like oh I got an empty
Warehouse really that's incredible
wow three-year-old shoe three year
easily three years if this shoe is three
years old it would just it would be to
be sitting there talking to me on the
mic
because it stands to reason all of your
shoes have that attribute well I'm a one
shoe a Time guy oh you really I don't do
the multiple pairs some kind of rapper I
forgot that one all right well then
that's I got a pretty heavy rotation oh
that helps yeah that definitely does
okay to the ground look mow the lawn
spots TV taping you name it and then and
then you're like it's time yeah
be uh you know sweaty inducing when when
do you know they've had enough what's
your what's yours I usually I go with
the hole in it
you know the top you gotta form a whole
something has to happen yeah I use the
whole Buffalo okay yeah yeah but it's
interesting too I find that I need
different types of sneakers for
different depending on the outfit I'm
wearing right these don't go with a lot
of the pants right what do you do there
this is it that's it they're getting
what they get if I'm going to a wedding
I'll throw on a black whatever sure you
know a dress shoe I have a dress shoe
and these
that's very interesting you minimalist
like that then very minimal How many
pairs of jeans you have
I go one it's like the shoe I go one but
I have a khaki I have a blue slack and
that's what's on and that's it so how
often are you washing those
sometimes never
mind
was the last wash wow something like
that
there's your pants yeah
what well I don't need anymore that's
wild how many underwear do you own I got
a lot of undies okay a lot of undies I'm
sponsored by sheath so they just keep
sending them thank God okay but you
don't what do you do if you stay in
those pants ah you get a little Rag and
you knock it out but I'm saying you
spoke ketchup on those that's not coming
out with just a we're getting a better
example yeah they look they look super
comfortable and the cuff is 10 out of
10.
a lot of people don't know how to do a
couple say it one more time see the wear
and tear that's coming through let's say
you drip Burger grease on those yeah
that's not coming out with a rag so what
do you do I think if you wear it long
enough it Blends holy I gotta go
back to the flipping of the underwear
please because you just said that you
have so many because they keep sending
them yeah so why do you feel the need to
double up on the underwear mind you
the stuff that was no good on the inside
is now on the outside and rubbing up
against those pants rubbing up against
your one of three pairs and now when you
put on her fresh underwear those
underwear are going to be contaminated
by the inside of those pants that are
always brushing up against the flipped
underwear interesting you you make a
good point but you know these Cowboys
they wear jeans for years yeah
yeah
you're not supposed to learn what about
your wife like does she she can
appreciate it she's uh if you're wearing
a flipped underwear she's does she even
know is it times that she are there
times she doesn't even know yeah of
course I mean we'll get down and dirty
and the undies are off immediately well
you get dirty that's for sure yeah yeah
you make out we're in the bed and she
doesn't she doesn't see the underwear
right okay I also walk out of the
bedroom backwards
wait what I don't want anybody seeing my
ass
you walk out of the way anybody
it's just her I can't I can't have
anyone seeing my it's a it's a
mental thing is your Exposed on
a general walk well the crack you might
get a a glimmer of light shining right
onto that balloon knot okay okay all
right so so so also ball bag doesn't
look good from the back the back is all
bad so from day one you've been backing
out of the room yes with with your now
wife still known her six seven years
never seen my ass
once I got pegged but other than that
you'll get up and she's there and you're
all right
I've seen a little bit every time and
you walk out like that and it's I give
an SNL wave it's not even a thing yeah
she's not she's not like stop it turn
around no I'm your death do us part no
no no not at once it's a thing now
she didn't want to see your ass then no
I don't think she does and I don't blame
her
it's not a badass I just I just don't
it's the same with a flaccid I won't
show anybody that either okay our wife
has never seen your flaccid penis maybe
she's caught a glimpse but if I can stop
it I will but I mean you get out of the
shower she doesn't see you naked or
something I turn
I understand that I'm not comfortable
with nudity in general as well same yeah
I understand that I understand that one
time when I was little I ran out of the
bathroom uh and I went down the hall to
go to my room and the babysitter was
already there but my mom hadn't left yet
and the babysitter walked into the
hallway while I was running nude and
everyone had a laugh a cute little laugh
I was you know younger but I to this day
is that's burned in my mind I felt
mortified yeah yeah and that's when
you're allowed to have a tiny right oh I
was the ass she saw oh oh sorry sorry
but you know what I mean yeah as a kid
you can you can yeah no have a genital
area nobody cares nobody cares I don't
give too much of a you know you
should Sun's got some looking at you I
mean this is this is wild your son's got
some penis on him have you thought about
going to Olympic
I knew you were going to make a a joke
that that was disgusting or something
like that uh
[Laughter]
why did you look at your watch on that
605. it's uh called Joe gross time
um no I don't it's funny though because
I'm like I'm like you're you're in
pretty good shape you're no hesitation
out the shower even with a gal it's new
no I'm not saying I'm no hesitation but
like I get comfortable pretty fast I'm
just like I don't know but I also too
I'm a big believer in if I ever and I
say this all the time to people and then
they argue me on it and whatever I don't
want to open a can of worms but if I
ever do get married or end up in a
committed relationship I'm a big
believer in separate houses oh really
because it's like I don't believe it I
think sharing a bathroom is gross like
like it's cool I mean you mean separate
housing like a different bedroom or did
you say separate houses houses yeah
that's the thing now I'm sorry I've been
a believer in that since I was in 1930s
the thing now is that people get married
and then have separate addresses yeah a
lot of people do that Who's Next Door
house to house
you know does that is a Hell in the
bottom Carter and Tim Burton I think
it's well they broke up oh well okay but
they do that no they have sections of
the Mansion no no they had two houses
next to each other
and they both want to decorate it
differently they couldn't agree on
anything so they just said yeah I think
I think if you're lucky enough to meet a
person that you that you want to spend
the rest of your intimate life with uh
like in a romantic sense or whatever I
think then on top of it
hoping that your living habits and
everything else like sync up is so
insane of course like and like I I just
it's just you're shooting for one in a
gazillion baffled the the the the the
Hallmark of marriage is companionship
you could so you can you can have
companionship without living 24 hours in
the same room the whole point is you
meet someone that you want to do that
with that's why you commit I think it's
one of those I think it's why so many
marriages don't work out oh you think I
got an Antiquity to take I don't think
it's Antiquated I think to look at it as
only that's the only way is is is
unrealistic potentially a mistake I
guess if it works for a couple but I
can't imagine that I would be missing my
wife I think they don't ever lay down
together I think it's good to miss your
wife that's the other thing oh but I
would miss my I would miss my wife
even if I lived with a oh shut up
come on do you not you go on the road
you missed your wife I think the road
saves the marriage wow not in a mean way
it saves the marriage I think so because
the road it gives you a little alone
time away and then you come back and you
have something to talk about you're not
talking about the same every day
can I say something though about our
lives because the my my girlfriend she
when we go away we go to work
and then she she gets the alone time in
the house time to herself time you know
in the dwelling you know to to nest
whatever the hell they do whatever
anyone does at their house when they we
don't get that so the time away for us
is different than the time away from
them we're going with other people where
we're on a you know sure a plane an Uber
a thing of that you know sure sure so I
would like I would like we're never home
alone right but think about it this way
back in the day you know when my parents
were working yeah my dad would go to his
office my mom go to her office they'd
leave the house at 8 30 they'd come back
at six and then they saw each other no
one texted no one emailed no one tweeted
no one said shared a DM wow that's the
road right well I go on the road and for
two days and then I come back
uh I watch certain couples whether
they're married some of them that I know
are married some of them are just
together living together but I watch
certain couples it's it's Madness it's
Madness they're together all day they
leave the house that's crawling each
other I'm like get Jesus Christ that's
unhealthy it's insane to me so I also I
shouldn't say my girlfriend we're we're
much closer than that but but but I
would say for me personally like like
I okay so I've my habits when I go to
bed right I have certain things I need
to do when I go to bed first of all I
steam the sheets yeah yeah yeah uh I run
crazy hot all the time I'm always hot
yeah but yesterday you weren't yesterday
on the hottest day in New York smell the
shirt yeah but the truth will find its
way out you're wearing cologne by the
way that's that's I sprayed it on
yesterday oh that's good
uh sinks into the shirt makes for a nice
day after smell you got that right uh
I I have my I run hot when I sleep like
crazy yeah and like like meaning like
I'm a guy that'll like sometimes run the
air conditioner in like December because
I'm like oh wow yeah I'm I feel like
that sometimes yeah I also need a
stimulant going when I'm going to sleep
I need to put like an audio book on or
whatever and white noise right same yeah
I need and then and then also I put
another layer on it because my favorite
thing to go to sleep to is usually
something horror movie related so you
need to see someone getting gutted my
point is I like a Stephen King audiobook
whatever I don't know it's just what I
like I meet let's say I meet the love of
my life and she's like
uh I'm always cold and I need to go to
sleep in dead silence yeah so what I'm
not gonna marry this woman because we
could never sleep in the same bed
together or I'm gonna go okay then let's
have separate sleeping situations and be
in love and have a great time ah you're
doubling your bills
uh bills it's love baby what are we
talking about you're doubling your bills
If It's Love babe you would live in the
same thing but you can't always do it I
watch like people like in marriage at
certain marriages and they're like
they're like they like want to rip their
hair out because like she won't stop
leaving her dishes in the sink or
something I'm like can I throw what they
said this is what we call compromise
which you're not willing to do there
yeah steamy so
I like a noise too she doesn't right so
I do a headphone in
I'm fine with that okay so that's a
compromise I like AC she doesn't and so
I go AC and I bought her a blanket
okay so there's ways okay that's fine
though the thing I'm thinking of most
with trying to sleep is um
that's that's caused me problems when
dating is the girl will want to cuddle
and I'm literally like
I'm the same way like kind of not
shoving but you know kind of pushing
because I'm hot in the middle of the
night and and they get offended yeah
yeah yeah so I don't really know how you
fix that
how do you fix that
huh put it put a cap on it say come on
for 15 minutes then bedtime that's good
it's it's middle of the night cuddling
though oh you gotta live in separate
homes you got a Clinger you know I don't
know also too do you do you wanna do you
wanna I mean look I I've never lived
with a woman but I I can't imagine I won
a scenario where I'm walking into a
bathroom or vice versa and we're
smelling each other's uh fecal remnants
[Music]
well my wife luckily doesn't she's
never dumped
she doesn't my lady
you've never seen it happen never seen
it and I love it I love it
oh it's like probably like tag on to the
very beginning of like another shower or
something when she's in there the
bathroom's closed and stuff I mean she's
doing it you ever like she's doing it
yeah I know she's in there doing it but
she's so she's like the way I'm
with my I don't want anyone
seeing it okay so she figures out all
these ways
that's a problem I'll get the door open
I got a one leg up yeah it's bad
the actor the smell of it is fine but
just a glimpse of it yeah she'll talk to
me I'll be and then you can
hear pool balls hitting the water and
she's just like so what are we doing for
dinner tonight I'm like
that's such an inconvenient way to have
to live forever for her yeah
she's not willing to compromise you're
why you're doing an LBJ dude well she's
fine with it that if she was upset with
that would stop I got it yeah that what
he just said is you got to put that out
of your head you live with the person I
mean like it's just like look you know
you're not you don't have to outwardly
you know part of this also might be too
that because I've been a bachelor my
whole life I've only lived in one
bedroom apartment right so in my head
when I picture it I picture somebody
being inside my one bedroom apartment
with me this is crazy you're setting
yourself up to fail I think you're a
little scared of commitment maybe scared
of marriage as I am too and so you're
building up all these oh this is gonna
happen you're making up problems that
haven't even happened yet sure that's
true that's true all right yeah well
what you just said though the dinner
thing he just said was nice huh well you
just said the dinner thing but not the
part but uh hey what do you
want to do for dinner I was like that
sounds nice like to have a person there
and you go it's pretty nice and she
loves to cook so then she'll be cooking
and I come up behind her and uh fish her
and then she keeps chopping up the
celery it's great then you go have sex
with no looking at each other's at butts
yeah well I see hers loud and clear I
mean I'm behind her it's amazing how
women are willing to let you see their
direct yeah right in front of
you I've always thought that's
fascinating isn't that wild yeah yeah
women are just they're okay with it I
guess they have to be yeah well they
don't have to be well
there's other there's other ways well
because they put a little duct tape over
it I mean what's the move but I mean
like you don't have to do it in that in
that position oh sure sure yeah I'm
gonna enjoy it
seem to enjoy the doggy
well anyway speaking of Mary
meat
we're here to talk about me where were
you at pip time wise
Whoa We flew by talking about we have
stuff to talk about let's see how far
this meets the question uh come on this
meat thing's gonna be great so I threw
an idea out and Sal's not on not loving
it and and Joe is seems very passionate
I think it's an excellent uh battle per
se I just don't know how how much I
could add to it you want that to come
your way no no I just didn't know if it
was on or not it is turn it up and make
it hit you too I don't want to lose Joe
no no it won't look how far it's going
that way we have the we have you gotta
get hit too it goes all the way to there
I'm getting hit from here they're
talking about a fan oh yeah babe turn it
make sure it hits you we got we have we
have the leeway finally have a fan I
have to run to the uh potty I apologize
oh geez so do we cut or do we keep going
just back out of here and keep going
keep going I gotta go with the door
open all right did you steam the shorts
folks let's talk about
Time game time is a long time time
sponsor at the taste buds POD at this
point uh and here's the deal you get
stressed out sometimes when you want to
buy tickets especially if you're trying
to buy last minute tickets to upcoming
events something you want to see a
concert a play a comedy show a sporting
event whatever it is game time is here
to help and relieve that alleviate the
stress really Flash Deals on last minute
tickets easy to find uh and and buy
those tickets for every kind of event in
your area images of seat views so you
can know exactly what you're going to be
looking at once you sit down and the
lowest price guaranteed events
cancellation protection job loss
protection Etc also if game time if you
let game game time guarantees you folks
okay I tripped up a little bit if you
find tickets in the same section it's
such a good deal it made me sure and
folks game time guarantees that you're
always going to get the best price in
fact if you find tickets in the same
section and same Row for Less game time
will credit you 110 of the difference so
snag your tickets without the stress
with Game Time download the game time
app create an account and use the code
taste buds for twenty dollars off your
first purchase terms apply again create
an account and redeem code taste buds
for twenty dollars off download game
time today last minute tickets lowest
price guaranteed
guys let's talk about mint mobile after
years of fine print contracts and
getting ripped off by big Wireless
providers if we have learned anything
it's that there's always a catch so when
I first heard of mint mobile uh that
they offer premium Wireless starting at
just 15 bucks a month you think what's
the catch right but after talking them
after using their service it made sense
there is no catch guys the secret sauces
they are the first company to offer to
sell wireless service online only they
cut out the cost of the retail stores
and those savings can pass along to you
we got a sample they sent us a card I
gave it to my assistant who is I'm not
going to say the service that she had
but she hated it and since uh she's been
using mint she has had no issues
whatsoever for anyone who hates your
phone bill mobile offers premium
Wireless for just 15 bucks a month all
plans come with unlimited talking text
and high speed data delivered on the
nation's largest 5G Network to get your
new Wireless plan for 15 bucks a month
and get the plan shipped to your door
for free go to mintmobile.com tastebuds
that's mintmobile.com tastebuds cut your
wireless bill to 15 bucks a month at
mintmobile.com taste buds
you're a little tight on the thigh yeah
yeah I got a lot of white meat over
there
oh wow
yeah you got to break denim in
especially after a wash yeah yeah here
here uh you're really leaving now huh
okay geez it's good huh what a what a
partner all the stuff we want to say
about them yeah so Joe deros is going on
a zembic so
send him your side effects your comments
your jokes trash him he doesn't want to
talk about it and uh everyone actually
you know what start do we everyone is
listening right now just start tweeting
Joe about him going on ozempic yeah just
start tuning at him ask him a bunch of
questions say we heard you going on
ozempic uh why and this and that why not
work out why not just work out what are
the pluses you see you know as because
there are pluses let's be honest sure
ask Joe let him explain to you
specifically you can't text him a tweet
him enough about ozempic pile them on
with those Embers please
oh this is the last time you were on
you know I got an Apple Watch oh good I
didn't think I needed it I I don't know
I I've done without it but uh people
keep telling me how you don't understand
it'll it'll help you with your keeping
your exercise like routines and sleep
it'll register you're sleeping I said
all right so I got it I've been having
like I have had it for like a a week I
don't know if I get it and she just
comes on and starts talking to me in a
moment I don't want another screen I'm
already looking at my phone too much my
iPad my laptop my TV now I got another
one I agree but what what I was told and
why I said the same thing is like that
this eliminates all this you get the
information in little blips and if it's
important you could you can go for it if
not you just disregard so you're just
doing this I guess you're supposed to
going and then doing this and then doing
this and then doing oh okay because I
don't need to be scrolling on Instagram
and you can't do that on that one yeah
and that's that is the good thing with
this so I had to do like that but it's
like I don't know she just keeps talking
to me she just said it did you hear what
she said what'd she say oh she said
something Siri wanted something oh well
but I don't say hey hey you could
probably turn that off
there's got to be a way to turn that off
but I didn't say it what did you guys
think of the new Apple headset thing
everyone's talking about is it the uh
headphones the guys like straps on your
face and it's virtual reality oh I got
the new headphones okay I'll pull them
up oh I think he said this is virtual
reality
a headphone yes
they got a new VR thing coming out it's
out he just it's out yeah he slides
right you can get it right now yeah I
guess apple is food technically so wait
wait so I could go buy one of these
today yeah
I don't think you can afford it but yeah
hey take it easy all right take it easy
I'm joking you own a bar
the uh no I uh they're a little clunky
huh it's a little clunky but it does
look amazing is this their first version
of this this is Batman AI now that we're
we're done that's over dude this is bad
that's why I hit the Big Mac we're done
dude this this topic permeates most
conversation it finds its way in because
that's what's on all of our minds it's
it's just it's I'm truly I've spoken
about it ad nauseum I just said but it's
like I feel that way I feel like we are
doomed I completely agree and it won't
stop just keeps telling me like chat gbt
I got the premium one like let me just
see it's amazing it's incredible I've
never touched it yet don't touch it
because it's depressing but it's also
impressive it's gonna take your job away
from you 100 yeah yeah what do you do
with it well I was like let me write a
joke in my style me I put my name in and
it wrote a joke and I was like this is
not bad oh we did that on the Pod but it
takes more to your level account
[Laughter]
80s comic and then the the up the new
one is like Louis CK wow it showed me I
have a theory about this I don't mean it
butcher box butcher box butcher box oh
gosh I love butcher box geez it's just
you know it's it's premium Meats at
amazing prices shipped directly to your
door I can't stand hunting down premium
Meats yeah for decent prices in the fall
in the in the forest and in the Super
Bowl exactly and butcher box is getting
me both those those qualities with my
meats and then sending them right to my
house it's Meat and seafood you could
trust everything is grass-fed free range
they got uh create free and wild caught
Seafood as well humanely raise no
antibiotics and no added hormones it's
delivered right to your doorstep there's
free shipping always free shipping
always and you can curate your box you
can pick a customized box you could
pause anytime I love it because when you
think sometimes you have an Impulse of
something that you want to have that
night and if you don't have it in stock
that means you have to go do a little
bit of a song and dance to get it but
since you get delivered all your meats
here a 14 pound box I get yeah when I
have an urge strikes me if I have an
urge for pork loin guess who's having it
right away yeah I'm having it it comes
to you it's it's it's very well packaged
it's preserved well and fresh uh it is
frozen you throw it right into the
freezer so you don't have to worry about
some you know beating the clock or
whatever exactly right uh I like the uh
steaks myself it's steak season it's the
summer I'm big on the steaks and butcher
boxes get me them steaks affordably
deliciously and all grass-fed I never
heard about someone being steak season
butcher box is giving us a special deal
sign up today put futurebox.com taste
buds and use code taste buds to get two
packs of bacon free for a year plus 20
off the first order that's
butcherbox.com taste buds and use the
code taste buds to clean the deal folks
Joe DeRosa here I am hitting that big
open road this fall September through
December and carrying on into the winter
but right now let's focus on those fall
dates Avenal New Jersey Toronto Ontario
Philadelphia Pennsylvania Salt Lake City
Denver and many many more dates are
being added constantly go to Joe
derosa.com for all information ticket
links where the shows are happening what
the days they're happening on is and
then by the way for all these I'm doing
the I Never Promised You a Rose Garden
show my new hour very proud of it I
think you'll enjoy it also go get that
salsa windfall single mouth on my money
it's available now on All Digital
platforms and on August 4th the
full-length album artificial birth drops
so excited for all of you to hear it
last but not least of course if you're
in New York come on down to Joey Rose's
seven days a week sandwiches good times
and drinks
joeyrosesnyc.com all right guys big news
I mentioned it before but December early
December I'm filming my special in
Chicago uh and I will not say where it's
going to be yet but the tour for that
special is ramping up right now starting
in August and going through to November
uh you can get tickets at savocano
comedy.com and these are some of the
tickets uh some of the places I'm going
now if this is this is coming out on the
13th uh with hey babe right so today is
July 13th the pre-sale is going on right
this second uh on sale will happen uh
tomorrow Friday July 14th so today is
the day if you want to beat everybody
out for those tickets the pre-sale is
happening at savocano comedy.com and use
the code no presh p-r-e-s-h I'm coming
through Bowling Green Cincinnati Toledo
Wilkes bar Wilmington Macon Georgia
Savannah Athens Georgia Peoria Rockford
Cedar Rapids Springfield Illinois Duluth
Rochester Davenport and Elkhart IN uh
Elkhart Indiana
um that is all uh in prep for the
special so go online right now and grab
those if it's not July 13th into hearing
this they're on sale so just get them
also
January is the Impractical Jokers cruise
with Eric Andre it's our fifth one and
we did it five times because it is so
goddamn fun so uh you get tickets there
get shipfaced.com and then of course if
you want to catch the Jokers on the last
weekend of this leg of the tour we won't
be touring again until 24. you can go to
impracticaljokerslive.com July 27th
through the 29th we're going to be doing
um St Louis Indianapolis and Nashville
at the Grand Ole Opry I hope to see you
guys on the road uh and I and I cannot
wait to do special so Chicago tell a
friend it's going to be great I don't
mean this is an insult but I have a
theory about this because you you're a
guy that does put up a lot of crowd work
videos yeah and they're that's a trend
in comedy Now hard work is becoming a
thing to the point where sometimes
people go to a comedy show and go it was
kind of annoying because the crowd
wouldn't stop yelling things out like
yeah yeah that's bad it's kind of
becoming what a lot of people expect
stand-up to be not good theory that it
it reflects directly with the AI because
there you using the comic as a chat GPT
and saying no no I'm going to feed you
something and I want you to produce a
joke about it for me right now and I
think that these two things becoming as
popular as they are right now is not a
coincidence I think there is a lot of
connective tissue between the two
between crowd work and AI because it's
look what you just said I fed it I said
write a joke in my name right that's
what AI is for a lot of people it's
feeding at something and saying spit
back out what I just said yeah I see I
see and there's a booming Trend in
comedy to feed the comedian the computer
an idea and then you go yeah yeah and
you go wow it's great I wanted to hear a
joke about that today I got it you know
right I I hear you you know in my
defense I only post crowd work so I
don't have to burn material yes yeah no
I know what you mean I'm not criticizing
saying I think
no but that is why I said I'm not saying
this about you I'm just saying in
general the idea of it sure what else do
you use it for give me past that because
that's all I would think well that's all
I know how to do or care about so you
just paid for it asked it to write your
joke and that's all that's your
experience with it yeah it was a free
trial but yeah yeah I'll cancel it
tomorrow but I just had to try it yeah
and it was not bad I mean it was a bit
it wasn't even crowd work it was wow
it's the number one thing in the in the
strike
would have not negotiate the studios
refused to negotiate putting chat taking
jet chat gbt off the table I don't blame
them because it's it saves them money
it's it's yeah but this is it this is
the end I know but this is how the horse
yeah that's true the horse and buggy guy
was like what was my life I make saddles
I have a barn but yeah but but I would
say the horse and buggy guy was the
horse and buggy Guy this is
the writer the performer the Creator
the barn Builder the Hayes bail guy the
the picker up we still got Barnes
all right when's the last time you saw a
barn no actually no
[Laughter]
this is a barn burner
I think you have a point but there was a
I guess my point is is the car the
automobile did not bring with it a false
intelligence
there's there's something it's essential
it's getting more and more sentient it's
wild yeah when you pay for it and you
pay for it and you go on are you asking
the same guy the same the same computer
like like is it is it is it one nuclear
like Nuclear One
yeah I know about a being
but the person that's the person the AI
That's responding to you is the same
exact code and AI when you buy it and
you buy it that is responding to you so
if you ask the AI to write a joke in his
voice would it spit out the same joke
that's a great question
would they say Mark already asked
I don't know I'm not joking but I really
mean like eventually I think it will say
that eventually I think it will I mean
look at that there's that guy that
killed himself because AI told him after
he had this long conversation with chat
gbts and you're better off take a breath
killing yourself or whatever you don't
have to do the whole thing without
breathing no did you see that what I saw
you almost struggling I'm sorry that was
probably a friend yeah kill yourself
[Laughter]
don't look at the man behind the curtain
yeah kill yourself so how is how is that
immediately not being like chat GPT just
it's important it was a fairly decent
service I mean look this is this car has
killed people too and they came out they
were running people like crazy but
they're not but they're not killing
people with with with an intelligence
there's nothing forget it I get it
here's the difference between the saddle
in my opinion the buggy saddle guy or
whatever the hell he said
um he uh they didn't say the car is out
so get rid of all of the horses we're
done with horses there was like a thing
where you could go okay well then how
else could we use the horses yeah but
it's very it minimizes the out of
it sure but also too what's happening
with AI is like it to me it's like if if
with the buggy analogy it'd be like if
the first Ford automobile came out and
it a year later was already in 1972
Mustang oh that that I agree with this
it's like it is evolving so quickly like
when the creators of AI start saying
like or not creators but people working
with developers rather start saying we
please government step in and like
congratulate this yeah there's no
industry where where the industry the
people in the industry are saying please
step in a thousand of them signed it
yeah it's a thousands oh is that right
yeah but they kept their money though
didn't they yeah they kept it
talking to chatbuck that's come on
boy this part has changed
let's talk about white meat and dark
meat
chat gbt which do you think is better
white meter uh don't do that you'll be
out of a podcast all right
[Laughter]
[Music]
I don't know why I'm trying to write a
bit around like why why did they feel
the need to tell us that their co-worker
couldn't be in why not just start the
news you're not them you're filling in
and no other job doesn't any bro had a
joke about that oh
really yeah that was a funny joke
you go there we go there we go there we
go Jim Jim Roberts camping Jim Roberts
isn't he said he goes nobody's sitting
at home holding his ears going no no I
want my guy I want my god
there was a little of that out there
there is a little of that out there like
if you were all of a sudden gone and you
put uh Shane Gillis in there everybody
would be way happier
you know what I mean people like that's
my guy like one time on my pod we
switched seats on accident and the
comments were like I can't live like
this my Skin's crawl out of my OCD and
I'm like we just change seats yeah we
had so many ones say to us uh because we
didn't we didn't get to the battle and
then we were like all right to be
continued we'll do the battle next week
and this woman wrote to us and said
can you please do me a favor and have
the courtesy to tell us when the battle
is not going to actually happen because
I spend my drive to work listening to
this right it's like sorry we didn't
cater to your life gosh yeah uh anyway
she's a she's our number one fan
uh
uh anyway all right you ready yeah all
right here we go time two
b-a-t-t-l-e budge all right Stark me
versus white meat yeah me and marker
team dark meat xiao's team white meat a
couple of darts over here yes take it
easy all right take it easy and then we
got a you know white C off to the left
yeah tried to balance it out did you yes
uh I uh here's the thing I can't believe
you prefer white meat it's insane well I
just think it just is juicier
and it is more appealing hit when I have
look this is how I know I don't like
dark you're floundering because I was
not even looking at what which type of
chicken I was eating a couple of months
ago and I was like oh this is
why does this taste like this and then I
looked and it was dark meat and I was
like oh I guess I don't like dark meat
this is it's what I told you before it's
what I imagined dog meat to taste like
you're using this dog can I just say
you're using this dog example a lot
lately you said it about hummus it's a
wet dog no hummus tastes like edible
throw up but you said wet dog with
hummus as well like you use the well
then maybe those two things yeah but I'm
just saying you're going to dog a lot
recently twice but anyway
good times but let's call let's call you
know just stop the press two times in a
short period of time um do you have are
you ever eating something sometimes it
happens to you with sushi I love sushi
but once in a while
I just go
I smell it and taste it and all of a
sudden I'm repulsified even though I
kind of like it and I'm like oh what am
I doing I'm chewing on this I know what
you mean yeah chicken it's been
happening to me lately where like
normally I eat chicken chicken tastes
like chicken I don't even pause I I know
what it's about to taste like it tastes
like that sure not even not even two
weeks ago I ate a piece of chicken and I
could couldn't even finish it because I
was like this tastes like
flesh of a chicken I don't know what it
is it just I was chewing I'm like all of
a sudden during The Chew I was like I
don't know I was eating a piece of
chicken once and I got freaked out
because you on the skin you could see
like the bumps from where the feathers
got plucked out yeah and I was like and
I was like oh my God I didn't like
really roughed me out and I couldn't eat
anymore it makes it real yeah so yeah
that's uh that that happens but what
does that have to do with white meat
well the taste of dark meat is that
brings that out for me I started chewing
I'm like oh this tastes like I it tastes
like it's not civil it tastes like what
we haven't come a long way we're cooking
food I just I'm like oh this tastes like
I'm eating a chicken so you have a
drumstick in your hand and you're going
oh this is repulsive I mean everybody
loves a drumstick I mean I've had a drum
I feel like the argument ends there the
drumstick that's it I mean the drumstick
you it's it's the it's the emoji for
chicken yes it's the piece of chicken
you think of any you think of fried
chicken you think of KFC you think Papa
anything you think of chicken hey you
want chicken for dinner in your head in
the cartoons the guy's head turns into a
drumstick how about those big turkey
drumsticks at the Super Bowl
so wait no drumstick has white meat none
none no that's dark no only the only now
a chicken wing is white meat so if you
get hot wings the drumstick and the hot
wings is white okay so that's now a true
drumstick is the leg of the chicken
connects to the thigh chicken quarter if
you will when they're still connected I
love the quarter oh yeah I mean it's
delicious is there darker meat than dark
is it levels of dark because you know
what do you mean what a deal no like no
no the singer like are there parts of
the chicken that it's like let's picture
it on a scale a gradient like a spectrum
right like is there like okay this is
kind of dark meat but this is like
really dark meat like if the drumstick
is like here but then another no it's
dark and light so so what color is dark
meat to you because I know but I will
say I will say that that some of the
white meat
is uh a bit fattier than like the breast
is the non-fatty part of the chicken
right okay pretty much that's why breast
meat so often is so dry when you do it
right though but but just hear my point
you you don't often get a dry Wing yeah
I mean like you've never you've rarely
had hot wings and gone like these are
dry well they're also covered in wet
sauce right what but I just mean when
you bite into it yeah yeah because it's
a fattier type of white meat uh but like
the the breast is is
that's that's I mean it's like fat free
basically I think I don't believe
there's anything yeah if you take the
skin off it is yeah like yeah that's
what I love it delicious
it can be yeah
it can be what color is dark meat
it might be just a hair darker what
color is it grayish that's disgusting I
would say gray it's off-white but isn't
it Russell like red and like isn't like
a bunch of different colors no but some
is light gray and some is like way
darker than the gray and it sounds like
has like that red no what you're
thinking of is the fact that the dark
meat pieces are much less meaty and
closer to the Bone a breast has no bone
in it except for the very bottom part so
when you cut into a breast you're seeing
a consistent color because there's no
bone obstructing it you cut into a thigh
there's literally a bone going through
the middle of it right the bone around
the bone is where the blood is and stuff
that's why they say it's chicken they
say if chicken if you're eating it and
you see blood as long as the blood's
near the bone it's fine it's safe I mean
for me this is strikes against you
see blood it's okay it's just that has
to be close to the Bone well you're like
a bloody steak
red or dark meat is made up of mussels
with fibers that are called slow twitch
these muscles are used for extended
periods of activity work walking red
meat all right then red sure uh but I
mean listen
yeah Mark makes a great Point since when
is blood and meat a bad thing I mean
they're bloody if you serve me a steak
and it's not bleeding I'm gonna throw it
but not in chicken
yes chicken properly cookies
on your chicken chicken should not
usually have blood they're saying if
you're eating chicken and you happen to
see some blood near the bone it's don't
pan and in your mind that this dark meat
is what it's it's tastier why
okay way more flavor what are you
tasting more of and it's juicier
it's not tasting more of something it's
like it's a 100 juice here 100 juice
here it's not about your taste have you
ever had the experience I had where
you're eating it not even that's not
even called chicken at first but like
you're eating something and you're like
I know that yeah it's supposed to taste
like this but all of a sudden this
tastes like I'm in my head about how
this tastes yes I already said that I
understood ribs especially you're like
this is a rib cage yes that's when I got
yes yes yes okay so that's what happens
to me when I have when I have dark meat
it's never happening with chicken I
literally told the story where it
happened to me uh two minutes ago I said
that exact thing happened to me I told
the whole story and you went okay for
the record you're in the majority see
where the plucks were capable oh no but
I'm not talking about the taste bro you
mean just the taste it's yeah yeah the
taste like I just like what I said well
I don't think
but that's all I said it was the taste I
don't think the taste you're not saying
The Taste you're I like the taste
nothing fat has you're saying when
something hold on you he he's saying he
asked about when you get freaked out by
a food here you're not saying because
the tastes no you're saying the idea
that it's a rib cage yeah I'm saying
because like she could see the flat
feather marks you're saying the little
literal taste I mean I think that could
have happened to you with white meat too
I don't see how that pertains to dark or
white meat chicken like you're uh
happens all the time with the dark meme
it just feels
uh I feel like I'm eating a chicken when
I'm eating the dark white meat all the
way dark meat looks like the inside of
Joe's heart black and full of hate there
you go curveball cards LLC yeah there
you go uh gotta give them the love I I
don't understand you're telling me Sal
when you eat fried chicken you get a
bucket of delicious Fried Chicken from
your favorite friend I always want that
drumstick first you're telling me you
don't eat those drumsticks and thighs I
think maybe in fried chicken maybe we
gotta get some fried chicken up here
yeah I think for fried chicken I don't
know if I discriminate in any way shape
or form with the meat but I do know that
I've I don't like dark meat outside of
that maybe at least
it just it freaks me out I don't know
also when you're cutting it and stuff
and I don't know just outside of a
outside of a Chick-fil-A Sandwich which
is a grand slam sandwich and white meat
okay I will admit to that
I would tell you that I think white meat
chicken
is the most boring food on planet Earth
I won't cross the street for a fried
chicken breast when I get fried chicken
I say I only want legs and thighs whoa
the only time if I'm ordering in a
restaurant that I'll eat like that I eat
uh white meat chicken I'm pretty sure is
if I get like I'll get wings I like
wings
I don't dislik I don't dislike white
meat but I find the only preparations of
it that make it enjoyable it it's got to
be doused in like a cream sauce or
whatever you know or you gotta or you've
got to do a hammered chick like a
chicken cutlets yeah but you're
hammering that thing so thin and
covering it and shredding and then
basically deep frying it you know like
you know these are talk to me on
Thanksgiving
okay I love that turkey leg Yeah that
turkey leg I love but again I'll do the
white meat if it's covered in gravy and
I get a scoop of stuffing I got a stupid
I gotta tell you what green bean with
turkey outside of lunch meat forget it
the white meat offends me on
Thanksgiving and I get pissed if that's
all that's left you're like the Native
Americans oh dude I put that dark meat
down because you can taste the white
meat through all the others oh yeah you
put that dark meat down and the the
juiciness and the ingredients in it and
the stuffing and the gravy by the way
you
dark meat looks like
gravy's coming
hard
now we're talking it looks a great point
it looks like golf in me it's like it's
gray it's unappealing if you had chicken
noodle soup with just white meat broth
it would be water
it's got no flavor no I don't mind I
don't mind chicken broth or bone broth
no no I don't like that the flavor is
the dark he's got a good point there
dude it's got a really good point too
it's got this Sheen no it doesn't that's
not true for certain it does
no it doesn't it's just that your meat
is dry and then when you touch uh dark
meat too your hands get sticky
the hell are you talking about you heard
what I said I say I say
your hands get sticky it has like a
shine on it like a like a like a coating
please Google that that's not true what
you just said you just said a real
stupid thing just now but maybe
that's the moisture that the white
doesn't have
uh we're looking up shiny meat this is a
tough Google
yes
you got nothing here but your hands are
sticking from an orange too it doesn't
make it bad yeah
people who prefer dark mirror the people
who enjoy Lunchables as adults at me
they know what team I'm on right now
white meat what is this the taste buds
on yes
white meaty sawdust Joe likes dark meat
because it reminds me of what his heart
is meant well another hard one
abstain I don't eat meat well thanks
Laurel sorry what do you eat up there on
your high horse ever tenderize horse
I'll tell you that and bread up some
boneless chicken thighs for chicken par
yes John he's right did you ever go
boneless chicken thigh and then no
cutlets with that oh you don't even know
what a game man
we got it
that'll be a gift
[Music]
a lot
[Laughter]
he's got a dry sense of humor he goes oh
you mean not funny
very funny he was a funny guy yeah do
you remember his uh uh I beat cancer the
bit he had about the IB cancer posters
the the posters all around the city
where I'd be like hey cancer what's up
you were no match for me five years
whatever he he wrote a letter from from
cancer back to everybody he's like hi
Bob I saw your poster I apologize I
haven't seen you in five years I've been
busy murdering children anyway
[Music]
you just said it yourself wait what's
that but the skin is all the same of all
in the chicken
the skin isn't different I'm confused
this is one of these statements that
pisses me off dark meat is for losers
who can't cook and are too lazy to try
first of all I spelled two wrong it's
just a dumb statement yeah I I don't
understand what that means well I don't
even cook what are they talking about I
just like dark meat because it tastes
better I've been an average I'm not
reading that keep going and I think
you're in the majority here so so we
have to fight for our right I believe so
yeah I think so yeah I like my meat the
way I like my women dark and juicy not
dry and asking for a manager
from the the mountains that might be the
winter today holy wrong
ah these poor white women yeah they're
really getting hard these days
white meat all day no debate yeah you
might take this chicken isn't hard to
screw up especially over cook chips I
saw way more dry complaints than I
thought it's probably gonna be closer
than we think maybe am I a communist who
likes dark meat everybody I mean you
don't like a drumstick I'm confused we
all have a drink meat all the way
chicken nuggets for Life ah jot crispy
I'm glad you brought it up chicken
McNuggets
chicken McNuggets were they're still
great it's my name that's because
she crispy is something that happened
ja crispy because chicken me nuggets are
still awesome but when the dark meat
chicken McNuggets were game changers and
they took them away the original chicken
nuggets had white and dark you could use
that to defend that yeah the dark beat
ones were were uh boot shaped oh I
remember the boots yeah and you always
got excited when you had more bills they
tasted so good at McDonald's yeah
it was always like a weird it was in the
uh Burger King no no no it wasn't really
it wasn't like supposed to be shaped
like a boot it was just I had a weird
boot shape and that's how you knew that
was dark and then the circular ones were
white now they're all circular because
all they do is white
they only do white meat there it was the
boot the boot was better because you got
a better job it was dark meat buddy it
was dark meat God those were awesome
yeah we're giving you the boot now we're
talking all right all right while meat
might be healthier dark meat white meat
oh I thought she typed typo white dark
bees freaking okay we get it wait means
I just find the breast is so boring it's
like what a lady who's dieting eats like
take the skin off chicken breast white
beet it's just so Bland I guess you
could make that argument for anything
because if someone you know if Gordon
Ramsay prepared you a chicken breast
you'd be like this is unbelievable
that's true right that's true yeah I
mean you know but Mark Mark makes an
interesting point I have a point white
meat chicken
is the only meat that I could eat like
if I ate it all day every day like if I
over ate white meat chicken all day
every day I wouldn't have an ounce of
guilt no worry about it oh no and that's
because it's so boring and has no flavor
and you know what I mean like anything
that that where you it's like it would
be like I ate too many carrots today you
know it's just like I like carrots but
who cares you think if you baked a
drumstick right out of the package raw
to baking without putting any seasoning
on it yeah and then you bit it the dark
meat would taste good 100 yes I I
actually was thinking that earlier
that's the whole argument yeah I
honestly want to say earlier I feel like
there's no seasoning I I was I swear to
God I was going to say earlier if you
cook both with no seasoning the
drumstick would taste better still yes
and let me throw the comparison at you
and you're probably gonna throw me out
the window
eat a hard-boiled egg
you got the the the white part and you
got the yolk yeah the yolk is all the
flavor and the white part is just kind
of a shell or a vehicle for the yolk
right that's how I feel about dark meat
okay dark meat is the yolk right and the
white meat is just the boring upper
layer that's not flavorful egg whites
have had a decade and a half
I mean they're doing fine yeah they're
both doing fine white meat and white egg
shell what are you called egg whites
I'll say this too I'll say this too
about
that dark egg
I'll say this too about white meat I
cook I cook a ton of chicken because I
forget about that's what people say
about you well yeah you know I I've made
a name for myself yeah I but I cook a
ton of chicken because I am somebody
that with dinner like if I don't eat
meat with dinner I'm not satisfied
and because I want to try to watch my
cholesterol and stuff I end up eating a
ton of chicken because it's the again
it's a guilt-free meat basically yeah
except for the killing and the slaughter
right that part what are you gonna do
you'll be crowding but I have I have I
have missed seasoned or under seasoned
both white and dark meat plenty of times
or didn't turn out the way I wanted to
the white meat it is unsalvageable if
you do not season that exactly right and
then if you take the skin off of it it's
oh ketchup
what are you a socialist
on it's on Salvage
all right I'm talking about you know
dipping
dipping I guess so you need a dip
[Music]
you can under season a chicken a
drumstick and you're like you know what
man I can I can save this I can save
this I can I can I can add a little this
or that and it's back the depressed
you're like God damn it there's so much
there's so much in a chicken breast
there's so much of just meat versus skin
ratio and anything the dark meat it's
the perfect amount of meat around bone
it gets it the flavor I I will say
probably or or the juiciness rather
changes a little bit as it goes outward
from the bone you get skin around the
whole area there's some pockets of fat
and stuff breast is just like that's it
dude you got this much skin on the top
you cut through and then it's just
straight flavorless meat all the way
down here here that's a description that
you're saying but I I could bite into a
nice little juicy white chicken breast
and be delighted but it did you could if
you're seasoning it
I know but I'm telling you I'm telling
you as somebody that does cook I
understand the concept yeah but I'm
telling you somebody that does cook when
you get it uh God my nose it's just so
bad it's driving me crazy when you take
a if you get a package of drumsticks
versus uh two chicken breasts yeah
chicken breasts always come two in a
package drumsticks usually four or five
you could take those drumsticks you can
put them into
you can base them in a marinade whatever
it is whatever however we want to season
them my point is this the drumstick
Works circular much like the thigh is
both sides yeah the best the breast is
top down that's it so all the seasoning
on your breast goes on the top then the
bottom is cool that is so true the
bottom is pointless the bottom is just
rib bone that's it so nothing is getting
into the meat itself whereas with a
drumstick or a thigh everywhere you bite
it from is an area that got touched with
that seasoning preach baby that was
beautiful
hearty bite and you're biting the whole
piece of the chicken so that's not true
and on the other side breasts are so big
they can't I haven't put my mouth on the
on the flip side of a chicken breast
because I have
naughty I'll say this that flavor
I'll still get that I'll say this too
I'll nibble at it I cook a lot of whole
chickens all right that's all anybody
says you're getting you're losing you
you often lose all skin on top of that
Rest by the time you start trying to
season the chicken you know sometimes
you cut a few slits in to you know
whatever whatever you're not here
all you're doing is cooking chicken
so the hummus episode dog meat but
here's what I do wet dog you want to
talk about sicko I buy a lot of those
rotisserie chickens you know with the
Dome there you go I love them I can eat
them just plain Oh you mean the way they
package in the plastic yeah okay and
they got that gooey wet jizz on the
bottom
Cornish game hen
[Applause]
so you buy those prepared already
prepared okay and then you come home and
you heat them up no no they're heat baby
oh you
eating them you're eating them right
then you're eating the whole chicken or
the table no you go home with it it's
still hot yeah buy it hot it's like
buying it it's like buying it from a
restaurant or something okay yeah yeah
and then you come and you you you eat
the whole chicken like like you're a
cave person yes yes exactly you eat the
whole chicken in one Center I don't eat
it all in one sitting I'm not Ralphie
May that's what killed him but what I do
is uh I bring it home I pop that Dome
off you get that nice whiff and I
immediately flipped the chicken over and
eat it from the bottom really why
because it's all dark I don't to be the
white breast up top is is the the least
fun bummer I'm gonna I'm gonna go with
you on this journey because it has a
more tendency to dry out over time
yeah but I eat it just kind of like all
right I'll eat this part now you know
what I end up doing a lot of the time I
buy those sometimes too and sometimes
I'll I'll I have like on doordash I'll
like look up rotisserie chicken I'll get
it delivered because there's like
restaurants that specialize in it uh a
lot of the time
first meal I'll house all that dark meat
four pieces same two legs two thighs
right second meal day later
that white meat chopped up right into a
chicken salad
drench it in mayonnaise and salt and
pepper
salad which it that's comprised of white
meat I'm saying that's what I do with my
white meat leftovers a lot but you don't
see dark meat chicken salad there's dark
meat chicken salad sometimes really but
the only reason they put in a chicken
salad the white beans because it's got
no flavor no I think it's because it's
better it's it's it's it's it's it's
it's it's no that's tuna's there's
there's white and dark what about
yourself what about the um the
consistency of a dark meat love it you
know what it's like the white meat is
like a girl that you have to put Lube on
because it it's got nothing going on the
dark meat this it's all pre-lubed all
right
[Laughter]
we've all been with a lady Where You
Gotta Lose I told you I told you it has
some sticky on it wow it's got
a little natural it's loose the white
meat is not
no dark meat
it's going now you praise I'm not saying
sticky I'm saying raising the lube now
but you want your lady to have a little
natural
I don't want to have lube out of the box
dark meat is when you're having sex
is having sex with a squirter white meat
is having sex with a girl that goes do
you mind if I get my vibrator yeah oh
God you hear that voice it's not is that
what it's like yeah
we just lost three sponsors all right
you're seeing let's go to the vote gear
plug your plugs man you got a big one to
plug here today big smash thanks for
having me by the way of course Netflix
special one hour special July 25th
that's called Soup To Nuts and uh my
podcast I love it
let's go we might be drunk and uh you
guys have both done it with uh we got uh
Tuesdays with stories and I'm on the
road coming up big theater tour so
please buy those tickets congratulations
huh the Vic is where you did it yeah
how'd you like it I loved it I'm doing
I'm doing mine there in December oh
great I wanted to ask you about it feels
like a club yeah you're gonna love it
that's awesome congrats I said you
yesterday I want to come back on we
might be drunk but I want to come on
when you can actually drink after oh
after the Pod yeah all right come on
because we have like three and then
you're like I gotta go do spots and I'm
like no let's go out man all right let's
do it let me ask you you want to get all
toast
and you still remember to walk out of
the room backward
oh oh with the lady yeah uh yeah it's
like you never thought your mind like
you have a blackout maybe she has seen
your ass
uh no but by then she's passed out okay
uh all right here's the vote Humble Pie
we got 7 000 votes
let's go ah I told you man we're in the
minority
all right your drum roll we got the
white meat winning with 59.5 to a 40
points we got trounced yeah that's not
that's not too bad you've seen we've
said we've had some 90 10s oh wow really
yeah maybe it's not too bad even after
all those great diet tribes you had yeah
I know that's yeah what are you gonna do
what does it say to you though that the
collective masses agree
that white meat is better why it says
what I've always said about the
collective masses they're dumb dull and
boring and have no taste or aesthetic uh
console the 59.5 of the 7 000 votes
that's all of them yeah every last one
fair enough that's all I need you to say
okay love me too
taste buds they come into the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two Fool's
gonna fight but only one food can be
right taste buds man yeah they're coming
to them